[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal sur tv 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 17 juin voici les titres de
cette édition
l'annoncé a été faite dimanche le
protocole dévoilé hier à partir du 22
juin l'école re devient obligatoire pour
tous les élèves de la maternelle au
collège
une mesure qui laisse perplexe les
parents notamment sur la capacité des
établissements à accueillir l'ensemble
des élèves
interview depuis lundi les salles de
sport sont autorisés à rouvrir
certainement fait d'autres se préparent
en attendant cet établissement de
montigny le bretonneux s'est adapté au
contexte avec des cours en visio ou en
extérieur
et puis vous avez peut-être suivi le
parcours de cette yvelinoise à la
télévision delphine a participé à la
dernière saison de l'émission koh lanta
l'aventurière de montigny le bretonneux
revient sur son expérience
mais avant de développer ces titres le
point sur l'épidémie de coronavirus dans
les yvelines est les chiffres des
hospitalisations sont encore à la baisse
sur le territoire cela concerne 459
personnes soit 7 ans - en 24 heures hier
mardi 26 patients étaient toujours en
réanimation et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire on dénombre 500 dit
victime de lakovic 19 morte à l'hôpital
un décès supplémentaire entre lundi et
mardi deux mille trente six personnes
ont été guéries
après un passage à l'hôpital
[Musique]
l'école va redevenir obligatoire pour
tous de la maternelle au collège et ce
dès lundi prochain le 22 juin annonce d'
emmanuel macron dans sa dernière
allocution présidentielle
comment les parents d'élèves réagi style
à ce retour en classe on va poser la
question à marie ou des bons soir
bonsoir
vous êtes la présidente de la pub
guyancourt peps et la première
fédération de parents d'élèves en france
déjà avant de vous faire réagir assez
récente annonce le retour à l'école a
déjà eu lieu depuis le 11 mai
réouverture partielle pour les écoles
avec un retour au cas par cas qui se
fait sur la base du volontariat pour
votre cas personnel marie audet vous
êtes maman de deux enfants l'un a repris
tous les jours en ce1 l'autre deux jours
par semaine en classe de cm2 et en même
temps vous télétravailler depuis votre
domicile comment vous avez géré cette
situation
alors c'est pas tous les jours facile
parce qu'ils n'ont pas tous les jours le
même planning les enfants planning c'est
pas les jours en commun les jours en
commun mon employeur m'a obligé à
retourner au travail
travailler et les autres jours je suis
avec mes deux enfants à faire leurs
devoirs plus mon travail donc c'est pas
ça reste encore très très compliqué a à
faire tout ça mais comment on organise
justement sa journée en étant en
télétravail est gelée compris en même
temps en s'improvisant enseignante du
coup c'est s'improvise tout à fait
enseignants c'est compliqué parce qu'en
plus je travaille dans un service rendez
vous donc on est obligé d'avoir des
scripts et d'être téléphone donc on va
dire entre de mails et de coups de fil
on fait apprendre des mots ont fait
apprendre une leçon
on voit là donc c'est pas tous les jours
facile même pour les enfants ça a été
très très c'est toujours très compliqué
d'apprendre tout avec un terrain demi
enseignants qui qui ne connaît pas
forcément la leçon on connaît pas la
leçon et en même temps on travaille donc
c'est très compliqué puisque pour votre
enfant vous ne le confirme et en plus de
ces jours de présence de jours par
semaine à l'école il faut des jours de
travail à distance en plus de séjours en
présentiel
oui il ya toujours les devoirs en tout
cas des choses à faire à distance
donc il faut toujours le faire à
distance pour ma fille qui est en cm2 le
lundi mardi c'est tout et à distance et
il faut faire tout ce qui est à distance
donc ça c'est pour votre cas personnel
est ce que c'est le cas de nombreux
parents aussi à guyancourt
c'est le cas de nombreux parents il ya
beaucoup d'enseignants a dû en cours qui
n'ont pas repris en tout cas jusqu'à
nouvel ordre qui n'ont pas repris et
donc c'est compliqué pour les parents
qui sont restés en télétravail et avec
leurs enfants à la maison et c'est
encore plus compliqué pour des enfants
qui sont en maternelle normalement où
les enseignants n'ont pas repris et
s'occuper d'un enfant de entre 2 ans et
5 ans et c'est pas autonome donc les
parents y sont et les travaille plus
avec leurs enfants dès fois deux voire
trois enfants de là et c'est assez
complexe et pour ces parents là et c'est
le cas tout à fait à vue en cours et la
ville n'a pas mis en places d'accueil
pour ces enfants dont les enseignants ne
sont pas revenir ou mieux sont pas
prioritaires
on l'a compris situations complexes pour
vous qui êtes maman qui doit gérer aussi
cette situation télétravail et en plus
de cette casquette de présidente de la
tête de guyancourt
on imagine que dans cette situation la
paix pas été au contact
en accompagnement de ses parents qui
étaient aussi en difficulté pendant
cette période alors oui on a été à
l'écouté de ses parents on a essayé de
trouver des solutions à ses parents en
appelant la mairie en demandant que ses
parents étaient dans le besoin
la mairie nous a dit que je pouvais rien
faire donc oui on est à l'écouté de ses
parents là on espère que pour le 22 juin
ayez plus enseignants qui reprenne et
que plus d'enfants vont pouvoir
reprendre
mais quand on doit le protocole on vient
de nous sortir fait réagir dans un
instant sur ce protocole donc je le
disais tout à l'heure vous l'évoquiez
emmanuel macron a décrété le retour
obligatoire à l'école à partir du 22 jan
et ce pour deux semaines avant les
vacances alors ça concerne tous les
élèves de la maternelle au collège les
élèves de lycée ne sont pas concernés
comment vous les avez accueilli
ces annonces comment les parents du
encore les ont accueillis est ce que
c'est plutôt du soulagement du stress
supplémentaire alors dimanche soir
c'était du soulagement séance est bon de
se reprendre on va pouvoir aller
travailler ces bombes ou faire du
télétravail pour tranquillement lundi
matin monsieur blanc coeur a annoncé qu'
il y aurait un mètre de distance
latéralement par enfant donc ce n'est
pas possible on peut pas reprendre tous
les enfants y guerre devant certaines
écoles et directeur commencé à dire que
on ne pourrait pas reprendre tous les
enfants mais on attendait le protocole
il devait sortir hier le protocole mais
je viens d'apprendre juste avant qui
vient de tomber
donc là c'est compliqué il faut mettre
en place un protocole on vient
d'apprendre aussi par ce pot de colle
qui est normalement tous les maternelles
pourront être au prix n'est dans les
classes élémentaires et collèges
il va falloir faire ce maître latérales
et des tous les enfants ne pourront pas
reprendre
on sait pas comment c'est ces puits de
l'obligatoire parce que ben emmanuel
macron nous a dit obligatoire est normal
et non ne sommes pas dans l'obligataire
est normal messieurs vous parler de ce
maître latéral qui est désormais
obligatoire avant en précisant qu'il y
avait la nécessité d'avoir un espace de
4 mètres carrés autour autour de
l'enfant on a du mal à imaginer dans des
classes qui sont parfois petit que le
maître de distanciation puisse être
respecté
vous le dites c'est aussi la réserve que
vous portez cette annonce du président
c'est exact une claque fait à peu près
en tout cas sur lui en course à fait un
élément cas ça fait cinquante mètres
carrés 50 mètres carrés il faut mettre
les élèves au maître l'enseignant si on
met les tables promettent ils ont tous
des armoires dans les classes donc on ne
peut pas enlever les armoires il faut
laisser un sens de circulation dans la
classe donc on va pas beaucoup augmenté
le nombre d'enfants en fait c'est le
souci qui va avoir
bah oui peut-être de 15 on va passer à
10 c est tout va mais si on les classe
de 29
on ne pourra jamais prendre tout le
monde et il ya beaucoup de classes de 29
et oui ça existe et c'est le problème
c'est que tout le monde ne pourra pas
reprendre un dernier mot sur les enfants
est ce qu'ils sont quand même tout de
même enthousiaste de pouvoir peut-être
retrouver les camarades avant de
avant de partir en vacances alors ceux
qui ont repris le 11 mai ils étaient
tous contents il y en a qui ont repris
le 2 juin aussi ils étaient contents
après je pense que oui ils sont contents
de se revoir mais en quinze jours on va
pas faire grand chose
et puis il ya d'enfants plus on va trop
bien se laver les mains et donc on va
moins travailler mais au moins ils vont
être contents de se retrouver avant le
départ au moins une dernière fois merci
mario des d'avoir été avec nous et je le
rappelle vous êtes la présidente de
l'apts de guyancourt puisqu'on parle
d'éducation c'était aujourd'hui que
devait se tenir le premier jour des
épreuves du baccalauréat les terminales
aurait dû plancher ce matin sur la tant
redoutée épreuve de philosophie un
examen qui vous le savez en raison du
contexte sanitaire a dû être repensée et
totalement tourné vers le contrôle
continu dans l'académie de versailles
qui regroupe les yvelines l'essonne les
hauts-de-seine mais aussi le val d'oise
ils sont plus de quarante et un mille
candidats en filière générale concernés
par cette cession 2020 du bac un peu
particulière près de 14500 pour le bac
technologique la résultats attendus pour
le mardi 7 juillet
[Musique]
le second tour des élections municipales
approchent c'est le 28 juin prochain
d'ici la présentation des candidats dans
nos éditions à la verrière nelly duthu
est candidate pour un troisième mandat
sa liste la verrière en commun est
arrivé en tête au premier tour nous lui
avons donné deux minutes pour vous
convaincre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a une liste qu'on a voulu très
équilibré dans chaque quartier on a le
même nombre de candidats nous avons des
gens de de grande qualité je trouve de
et de compétences d'analysé d'expérience
de formation une liste rajeunie par
rapport à celle du mandat précédent
puisque la moyenne d'âge est de moins de
45 ans en même temps une liste
d'expérience puisque un tiers de
personnes qui la composent ont déjà eu
une expérience d'élu municipal un thème
fort et reste le même que commanda
précédent c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
concerne en priorité la jeunesse et on
va de la crèche une nouvelle crèche et
crèche collective qui permet une
éducation forte
on va passer par l'école où là on va
aussi augmenter notre capacité à aider
les jeunes dans leur scolarité et on
continue de façon très logique avec les
plus âgés sur l'aide à la formation sur
l'aide à l'emploi que ce soit avec
l'emploi d'un agent fait pour ça ou la
création de ce qu'on appelle une régie
de quartier une de mes premières
décisions va être de faire revoter la
création d'un médecin d'un poste de
médecin municipal ça devient une urgence
ce qui vient de se passer pour ce
confinement dans ce que cette endémie
nous montre à quel point ces déserts
médicaux ne peut ne peuvent pas perdurer
que ce soit dans les hôpitaux mais que
ce soit aussi dans la médecine de ville
[Applaudissements]
et ce sera donc une triangulaire à la
verrière tout comme à plaisir trois
candidats sont également engagés dans le
second tour des municipales
annie joël prio hasseni et mènent toutes
à faire pour plaisir qui s'est classé 3e
le 15 mars dernier
présentation en 2008
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
taf tout à faire à plaisir c'est une
force tu as fait une force positive
constructive
porté par des femmes et des hommes qui
vont à la rencontre des plaisirs war
pour changer pour construire des idées
de changement pour la ville une force
centré sur une intelligence collective
et de partage il repose en tout cas sur
une politique des besoins auxquels on
adapte les moyens et il ya un fort
besoin un plaisir ce sont les liens les
liens entre les quartiers les habitants
les liens de circulation de mobilité
douce et on a une proposition
proposition de maison citoyenne que l'on
va retrouver dans tous ses quartiers et
tous les lieux de vie où il ya des
besoins
ces maisons citoyennes regroupe on fait
des permanences de services sociaux de
service public des activités culturelles
sportives remettre en place des
structures de jeunesse délai ouvrir les
stades les équipements sportifs ouvrir
les commissions municipales aux plaisirs
ouah c'est à dire que vous savez
aujourd'hui les commissions municipales
regroupe des des élus et des services
donc on les use ou aux plaisirs oies et
des référents plaisir de chaque quartier
je pensais aux commissions municipales
qui n'existe pas aujourd'hui comme celle
de la santé et du handicap
bien sûr un plan d'urgence il faut
lancer à plein de plein d'autres plans
d'urgence sur les mobilités douces et de
circulation et avoir une réflexion
globale d'une politique familiale qui
doit être absolument restructurer
notamment je pense aux tarifs municipaux
de la ville qui doit être changé
[Applaudissements]
et en complément de ces présentations
nous vous proposons également des débats
en vue de ce second tour des municipales
ce soir à 20 heures
c'est avec les candidats de
voisins-le-bretonneux c'est à voir sur
tv 78 et à écouter également sur les
ondes de radio sensations yvelines
fréquence à 98 points 4 dans l'actualité
ces images qui ont fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui plus de 500
personnes qui se sont rués à un magasin
d'une enseigne de discount d'orgeval
elle a raison une promotion très
attractive une célèbre console de jeux
vendus à 95 euros contre 300 en temps
normal certains ont même passé la nuit
devant le site pour espérer profiter de
cette réduction
les événements ont vite déraper ont
nécessité l'intervention des gendarmes
dans la cohue une personne a fait un
malaise et un gendarme a été blessé à la
vente a été finalement annulée
l'enseigné allemande de 10 quand indiqué
qu aucune communication n'a été faite
sur cette promotion est qu une photo à
titre privé a fuité malencontreusement
sur les réseaux sociaux culture et une
saison bouleversée pour château de
versailles spectacles par la crise
sanitaire de nombreux événements prévus
pour le début du printemps et est
finalement reporté voire même annulé et
les jardins sont restés à moitié vide
mais l'activité a tout de même repris le
reportage de mathilde et demi avec la
crise sanitaire beaucoup de projets ont
dû être reportés voire annulés par le
château de versailles spectacles depuis
la réouverture le château n'accueille
que 500 personnes par heure les grandes
eaux musicales qui devait débuter fin
mars ont finalement commencé trois mois
après en juin l'activité principale elle
se fait aussi beaucoup au moment de la
reprise de la haute saison
donc là on devrait pouvoir
grosso modo pour une dizaine de ses
spectacles les accueillir dans la saison
qui arrive
donc on les a décalé dans le temps et ça
permettra de faire jouer les artistes
qui sont aujourd'hui beaucoup à la peine
est également de donner au public qui
vient les projets qu'ils avaient envie
d'entendre que ce soit en musique en
danse en grands projets et puis l'autre
aurait été littéralement reporté d'un an
je pense au bal masqué par exemple aux
fêtes galantes ou à versailles électro
qui devait accueillir 18 mille personnes
eh bien on les attendra un an plus tard
tout simplement jour pour jour les
secteurs du tourisme et de la culture
ont grandement été touché par la crise
sanitaire les spectacles reprendront
lors de la saison 2000 20 2021 entre
octobre et décembre et la saison
musicale quant à elle reprendra à la fin
de l'été à l'opéra royal n'aura un focus
de chorégraphies au mois de décembre
ce que je crois c'est un mois où on aime
bien sortir en famille et bah c'était un
projet la chorégraphie qui peut
s'adapter assez bien aux enfants
il y aura une chorégraphie autour des
quatre saisons de vivaldi fait par
marie-geneviève massé
il y aura le spectacle de angelin
prejlocaj qui s'appelle voyage d'hiver
sur la musique de schubert
ça tombe bien ça sera en hiver où les
danseurs on va dire évolué avec un
chanteur et un pianiste qui chante les
lieder de schubert et le tout dans une
atmosphère allemande
on va dire de romantisme allemand assez
extraordinaire le même près d'oka genou
donnera un spectacle s'appelle la
fresque qui est une création dia trois
ans et enfin nous finirons l'année comme
nous aurions dû la commencer par
définition avec l'anniversaire de
l'opéra royal les 250 ans puisque ce
sera avec le spectacle chorégraphique
marie antoinette qui raconte l'histoire
de marie antoinette à versailles pour
patienter avant la reprise des
spectacles et activités culturelles les
grandes eaux nocturnes feront leur
retour tous les samedis soirs à partir
du 27 juin jusqu'au mois de septembre
il a retrouvé son public ce mercredi le
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines a rouvert ses portes
accès sécurisé et mesures sanitaires
mises en place avec toujours au
programme l'exposition le siège qui se
révolte qui met en avant une collection
de sièges et canapés design
elle est d'ailleurs prolongée jusqu'au 9
janvier 2021 les salles de sport elles
sont autorisées depuis et lundi par le
gouvernement à reprendre leurs activités
certainement pas attendu cette annonce
pour se réinventer en adéquation avec
les mesures sanitaires
à montigny le bretonneux cette structure
qui compte plus d'une centaine
d'inscrits propose des cours en visio ou
en extérieur le reportage de nickel et
demi d'euros des cours via écran
interposé depuis le 22 mars cette salle
implantée à monti le bretonneux a dû se
réinventer avec l'épisode du coc vite 19
les plannings ont été adaptés les cours
de yoga pilates et de renforcement
musculaire se font par petits groupes
une situation inédite pour la structure
créée il ya dix ans j'ai mis des cours
le matin à l'heure du déjeuner des cours
le soir
j'envoie des liens pour chaque séance
les élèves n'en voient leur leur
programme de la semaine
et puis après chaque semaine moi je
définis le planning qui peut changer
toutes les semaines en fonction des
impératifs des uns et des autres et puis
j'ai en moyenne j'irai entre cinq et dix
personnes par zoma chaque court et j'ai
une quinzaine de courts pour compléter
cette offre en ligne céline a décidé
depuis le 2 juin de donner la
possibilité à sa centaine d'élèves de
pratiquer des cours en extérieur au
programme aujourd'hui du pilates expiré
par la bouche décontracté votre gorge
vos épaules et vos bras inspiré par le
nez et tirez votre colonne vertébrale
comme si un film tiré par le sommet du
crâne
expirez bouche ouverte ça change que je
peux revoir les élèves que je peux avoir
plus de monde que si j'étais dans le
studio
parce qu'au studio avec les normes je
pourrais pas avoir plus de 4 ou 5
personnes et là je peux en avoir neuf
donc ça change beaucoup et puis ça
permet donc vraiment les revoir et
pouvoir bien les corriger des cours en
extérieur trois fois par semaine qui
séduisent les pratiquants
c'est super ce truc c'est une très belle
expérience c'est important de choses moi
depuis le début qu'elle en a proposé
j'en ai pas raté un seul au niveau du
pilat ton travail
le centre et ça change tous les repères
donc ça fait travailler différemment et
c'est intéressant
les cours reprendront l'intérieur le
lundi 22 juin mais vu le succès
rencontré avec ses cours en extérieur
ces lignes devrait continuer pendant la
période estivale
vous avez peut-être suivi la dernière
saison de koh lanta parmi les
aventuriers cette année une yvelinoise
de montigny le bretonneux
finn resté trente jours sur une île
paradisiaque a été éliminé juste avant
la réunification au rayon a recueilli
ses impressions au terme de son
expérience regardez j'ai participé à koh
lanta plus près les aventures physique
qui mène j'aime repousser mes limites
j'aime un beau challenge et et koh lanta
pour moi c'est le panel qui a permet de
regrouper le sport la dureté physique le
manque alimentaires le manque de la
famille
l'ennui parce que les gens de la
koh-lanta sont très nombreux on fait
très tôt on se couche on se réveille que
le lever du soleil
on se couche avec le soleil donc du coup
si 5h30 et 6h t bout du temps au nord
vers 18h 19h donc l'ennui et les
relations humaines parce que tu arrives
avec des gens que tu connais pas et tu
es en totale immersion avec eux h 24 7
jours sur 7 du matin au soir donc c'est
compliqué
le collier d'immunité saleh que j'ai été
chercher après avoir fait des 500 m de
nage ça restera pour moi le plus beau
souvenir
c'est d'avoir écouté mon affecte au lieu
d'écouter ma raison et d'avoir six
d'avoir été trop rouge et d'avoir pris
conscience que en réalité il n'ya pas de
la secte dans koh lanta comme le dit et
aura la confiance c'est bien mais la
méfiance c'est mieux et ça m'a coûté ma
place
puis attendre vu que que la pilule passe
et puis on s'est expliqués puis ça reste
qu'un jeu évidemment que je me suis
réconcilié mega man
j'ai beaucoup de contacts avec claude
jessica moussa donc c'est vraiment les
trois principales personnes avec
aujourd'hui je suis en campagne
je dis oui le challenge est à l'amertume
d'avoir été éliminé à la porte des
ambassadeurs véhicule
je ne pourrais que repartir pour aller
chercher la compétition quoi avant de
refermer ce journal une idée pour vous
aérer tout en restant dans les yvelines
les fermes de gally ont choisi de
diversifier leurs activités le
labyrinthe des petites foulées par
exemple aujourd'hui accompagnés de cinq
nouveaux parcours et de jeux en bois
mélanie poké a tenté de trouver la
sortie
aventuriers de tous âges la ferme de
gally vous lance un défi
arrivé à sortir de ces cinq labyrinthe
de celui fait de grille à celui en
bottes de paille il vous entraîne dans
le monde agricole
il ya un max pédagogique important il ya
un thème autour des vaches de race
dommage qu'on peut trouver en france il
ya un tas qui concerne toutes les petits
animaux qu'on peut trouver autour de
nous donc ça ce sont des labyrinthes qui
sont destinés principalement aux enfants
on a un espace dédié aux abeilles parce
que agali de la prise en compte des
abeilles le respect la protection des
abeilles est quelque chose de très
important notre labyrinthe de céréales
est très tourné autour de l'agriculture
des jeux et des animations qui
s'étendent sur quatre hectares avec un
livret de questions à répondre après
deux mois de confinement
le public familial répond présent très
distrayant bien bien construite
on a découvert un nouvel endroit c'est
pas pour les enfants profiter du beau
temps les parents ils peuvent aider
parce que c'est quand même un peu
compliqué je trouve ça très très bien ça
permet de voir autre chose sur le
domaine de gally où c'est vrai que c'est
un endroit où vient régulièrement pour
les enfants en ce moment c'est vraiment
l'occasion de retrouver le plaisir de
courir en plein air s'amuser et profiter
de l'extérieur des jeux anciens sont
aussi proposés l'eire 2e accueille du
public tous les jours de la semaine et
tous les samedis de juillet passereaux
en nocturne
il y a comme un air de vacances c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]